we have to do what we have to do to rid
ourselves of all this fears
your eyes don't deceive you that is
Oscar winner Brad Pitt singing during a
surprise Cameo on the Dave season 3
finale wow we're really going for it
here aren't we it was a big surprise for
Dave fans the a-lists are making an
unexpected appearance showing off his
pipes
[Music]
but the cameos don't stop there with
Rachel McAdams popping up as the lead in
Dave's music video I ain't playing why
you think I've been rapping to be Mr
McAdams
and drum roll please
hey Drake
what's up but back to Brad it's the
Natural Evolution Brad stars as himself
he stops by Dave's house to make music
but things take a turn when Dave's
stalker holds them hostage you guys
aren't like still thinking about the gun
are you
well I am now
but don't worry Brad hatches a plan for
their escape in the form of a song
[Music]
I know it's gonna die so let's like
let's have some fun before before we go
out
ow Brad inevitably took one for the team
allowing Dave to escape and visit his
Idol Drake in West Africa like I really
am like
I am a superstar I am worthy and I'm
special I appreciate that but when you
say it it's almost like you have this
like kind of undertone like there's like
an auto-tune crying under you oh in the
end Drake agrees to work with Dave after
giving him a hard time at first
that's good weird by the way just like
super intense first combo I was about to
ask if you wanted to eat but obviously
we went straight into positive
affirmation so anyway
how to love myself
no but this isn't the first time rapper
Lil Dicky scored a-listers on his comedy
series in Dave season 1 he partied at
Justin Bieber's pad and he met Kourtney
Kardashian what's it like for your
entire family to be the most famous
people in the world at once together
I mean I would rather do it with my
entire family than do it alone in season
two Courtney sis Kendall Jenner made an
appearance with her bestie Haley Bieber
you know what I mean like I'll rub my
Mound you know however
oh my God Benny you have to bring this
guy around more often no seriously I'm
obsessed with him there's a not safe for
work exchange with Doja cat and
appearances from Kevin Hart and Lil Nas
X I'm a talented cat although Brad may
not have been the first Cameo his
incredible performance will be a tough
act to follow
no wrong way
enough is enough
[Applause]
[Music]